hello everyone I'm here with Grandmaster
Bella Hotel Nashville Bella just won a
beautiful day the game today how do you
feel well after today's win four in a
row after your tough start uh yeah I'm
surprised then yeah I feel great that's
really good yesterday you had another
rest day yeah were you able to take some
time to yourself I kind of
did you spend a lot of time preparing
for today
what did you do yeah actually I prepared
party a lot but I did not prepared
against this variation okay it was
surprised for me
um I relaxed I tried to harvest some
rest
because
last three rounds are mostly very
important during the tournament so I try
to keep my energy
of course of course last rounds are
always suffered it sometimes doesn't
matter the start as much but if you get
to con Focus then the end you can do
really you can do really well and you
can change a lot of things I wanted to
ask you about Hobbies do you have any
hobbies things that you like to do it
can be Sports too
oh I like reading reading reading yes
gardening uh yeah uh the both Sports I
do yoga yoga and then swimming
mostly I love walking
do you spend a lot of time walking
during a tournament I know it's
important you play very long games you
know during the tournament I try to keep
my energy but sometimes I love to work
but for a much longer time okay so you
spend a lot of time preparing then you
play the game you relax a little bit and
back to preparation something like this
I see I do something that's a lot of
openings too repeat before the game so
I have to prepare very hard you have uh
two more games now I believe you're
sharing first at the moment that we're
recording this
um are you thinking about winning the
competition or you try to take it a game
at a time actually I try to do my best
I am concentrated on each game I don't
think about the results for now
maybe after tomorrow
sounds good and last question who is
your favorite world champion
it's probably Magnus Carlsen mine too
virtual high five I'll give high five
after arrival and thank you so much wish
you good luck in the last two rounds
thank you